thank you
[Music]
in Florida news
a man has been sentenced to 14 months in
prison oh really
shocking after being found to be putting
laxatives in his stepson's daily
medication oh oh he [ __ ] hates that
for all right but what's the reason he
hates that fool he wants his stepson to
[ __ ] his brains out waiting but for the
rational part but in this logic in
prison for that
in in his medication how do you put it
in your medication okay
first of all let me let me entice you on
on how horrific this actually I think
you get the medication
and then you put it in there
there's some laxative in pill form too
yeah you just dip it in so Craig Allen
Ripple anybody who's named Ripple by the
way age 54 was convicted of felony child
abuse surrounding the removal of the
child's medication
that's fine okay uh to mess with the
family literally to mess with the family
the sentencing comes three years after
Ripple's former partner and the child's
mother had reported that the 54 year old
had been tampering with her 14 year old
Sons prescribed drugs halfway in a child
child or 14. oh he's 14. yeah you could
probably asking for it there's [ __ ]
14 year olds on ESPN man [ __ ] 511 280
and [ __ ] Duncan Dude triple one million
this is uh this is Craig by the way
what's up Craig oh I don't like them
yeah he looks sketchy what does he look
like Jason he'll look like uh
wet potato
[Laughter]
scripture he looks like
looks like we're like Louie Anderson he
looks like Louie Bowser became human if
Bowser was also kind of looks like white
chairman mouth
there's a white Chairman Mao that fool
got an iodine deficiency dog he's got
that [ __ ] thyroid [ __ ] problems
that's such a roast you tell someone
they have a thyroid yeah
you need to have salt with iodine what
are you missing iodine I know the [ __ ]
is wrong with your neck check out this
guy yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] up neck man you
[ __ ] wet potato what potato is good
all right so this uh
the child was on lithium to treat his
mood and behavioral disorder he needed
that battery charge however
however for almost a year between 2018
and 2019 he had complained of persistent
diarrhea and abdominal pain pleasure
abdominal pleasure is that what you're
gonna say
man uh he even had to undergo
uncomfortable procedures such as
colonoscopies and endoscopies and
endoscopy endoscopies
I think that's when they shove a video
camera up your ass to see what the [ __ ]
isn't that the colonos
copy they put a whole some quarter up
there
that you had the foot on your shoulder
yeah so so he had to get all these
surgical procedures in order to diagnose
what was wrong with him but obviously
it's not like a common disease that like
oh your stepfather's how long was he
doing this for over a year hey don't
that [ __ ] you up like like don't you
gotta get constantly dehydrated like it
really [ __ ] dude diarrhea is a problem
you know what you know what sucks the
worst too is him being repeatedly told
maybe it's something mental
that's gotta drive you no like maybe
you're just stressed out or you're
getting poisoned by your father maybe
that's just how you [ __ ] dude everyone's
probably telling them like you gotta
drink more kombucha dog I know like it's
a prebiotics you got to get some Fiber
in there what's in your diet bro
so uh after the child's mother
discovered laxatives mingled into the
original tablets she decided to set up
security cameras across the house
detecting her then partner of suspicious
Behavior upon discovering Ripple's sick
Shenanigans she divorced him and met
with investigators dope and as if the
drug tampering ordeal wasn't enough of a
low-life move it turned out that Ripple
had been responsible for a number of
bizarre incidents just to mess with the
entire family as a whole what else did
what a [ __ ] face he would take and hide
the children's clothes and homework and
jewelry just to watch them and their
mother search for the items whoa this
guy's [ __ ] up that probably sounds
kind of fun though
no prosecution for that yeah yeah but
it's like wait a minute I do that I do
that but I it's funny diary is [ __ ] up
diary is over that's too far man yeah
too far most diarrheas are too I show
Taco one time when Jill's taking a
shower
and you just turn the handle cold and
she's not looking and she freaks out and
then he had a good time worth it that
was worth it no bodily harm because it's
a it's cold explosion it's good for you
yeah yeah hey but then you guys laughed
and it was a good time but this guy was
like oh yeah he probably saved the laugh
he went into the room later five minutes
later and then laughed it I don't think
he's laughing like evil laughter
like that I wonder
sometimes I wonder if if that was
happening to me when I was a kid I
really wonder if your parents were
poisoning someone was [ __ ] with me
because it was like there was a good I
want to say two years that I had like
Phantom [ __ ] stomach issues wow and I
got an ultrasound and I went to the they
were like one step before it [ __ ]
shoving the camcorder up it's kombucha
you need more kombucha you need more
prebiotics bro I had like and then I was
told like even the doctor was like it's
probably a mental thing you have because
so that's what you were drawing from
when you said this well because I yeah
because I got two stomach flues in a row
like week to week and then from then on
I couldn't stop feeling sick like I
remembered as a kid this is I was
probably like eight or nine and I
remembered to like I had a phobia of
throwing up because of that and then uh
I remember I would just [ __ ] read the
Bible to throw up damn I'll be like come
on God don't let me do it come on so I
would be sitting on the toilet trying to
[ __ ] it out and reading the Bible at the
same time so you don't throw up bleeding
for Mercy what uh book would you read
everything I was just reading I would
read the [ __ ] begats the things that
don't make sense because maybe your dad
saw that he goes you know what this is
making him more Christian
you have a moral laxative more
anti-pepto business that is diarrhea
Ministry baby is there a doctor Asian
yeah I think he was because I feel like
only Asian doctors would blame the
patient they make [ __ ] up wait you got a
fever yeah dude I think it's just you
man
Chinese doctor wants and he goes you
have a weak heartbeat yeah I was like
what a weak heartbeat because he was
feeling about pulse he's like yeah
you're so sweet man with the hair dude
what does that mean I don't know I think
you just couldn't feel my pulse it's
like you ain't vigorous
[ __ ] huh okay
yeah I did get that because then they
were like they were trying to see if
there was an ulcer that was like them I
had all the symptoms of having an ulcer
but they were like no ulcer dude like
maybe you're just like scared from it's
all in your head yeah and I think in a
way I've heard of God yeah there was
some kind of [ __ ] like I had some
stomach problems too where I wouldn't
[ __ ] for days oh yeah and it was so bad
that I had to go
um to get an ultrasound and then they
found a little [ __ ] baby Stuck like
yeah and then they're just like you
gotta eat more [ __ ] did you name it
intestinal stasis you gotta You Gotta
Eat fiber you gotta do this they didn't
have kombucha at the time you know I
love the idea kombucha is a new
invention wait so when you had that
little poop baby in you did you poop it
out
I forgot I I remember they gave me some
medicine Samuel it was that bomb ass
pink [ __ ] too Pepto-Bismol some kind of
drink I don't know I tried all that I
had to drink Mylanta yeah I tried we
tried all that because every time you
get a stomach ache I think Asian parents
either give you charcoal balls or Pepto
charcoal balls you never had charcoal
balls in the little they're like real
it's actual charcoal yeah and it's just
in balls it works amazing but I didn't
know I take the regular pills it smells
like medicine yeah it smells like
medicine right I had that one like
Chinese medicine yeah yeah I had that
one so what we have is like this this
old ass [ __ ] bio it's it's and it has
a trumpet on the logo yeah it's like a
[ __ ] trumpet and then they come out
in little black Dusty Balls I've had
those right that I thought those were
charcoal balls oh I don't know what they
were much yeah but they give us that but
then now it's like oh if the [ __ ] ain't
coming out then you shouldn't take Pepto
I don't know because Pepto holds the
[ __ ] if you have diarrhea oh pepto's an
anti-fucking diarrhea yeah kind of pulls
it together you need a five or one bar
dude that's what you need yeah isn't
that what Pepto is essentially do it
fibering it up he stuck uh that little
bullet in my butthole I've had that and
then it shot right back out and I was
like everything popped out I was like I
need different kinds of medicine was
that some was that really like a
treatment or is that some Larry nasso
[ __ ] that was going no that's some real
[ __ ] I had to take that I had to do that
bullet when I had hemorrhoids this was
like [ __ ] last year I was last year
yeah because a keto diet remember I told
you every time I do keto I get [ __ ]
hemorrhoids from space what does that
bullet do I don't know I had to do it
myself like every day I had to do it
like alone and I was like I there the
doctor like yeah you know just relax and
just stuff it up there I was like sounds
easy I went in the bathroom and I did it
and of course I'm looking in the mirror
and I noticed that as I did it I was
like crying a little I was like what the
[ __ ] why is that happening
it's like when he pulled a nose hair out
yeah exactly it does that effect I don't
think it's like pulling a nose hair up
this is more like pushing or something
else you have to push it beyond the
threshold of the shoot back out portion
oh so there's a part of your I don't
know you all know this there's a party
there's a part of your ass that
voluntarily wants to shoot it back out
you gotta go past that wow yeah until
it's accepting South of the Border baby
you gotta go straight through wow yeah
and then it'll shoot the other way and
it'll your body yeah it'll go come out
your mouth and then does it come back
out how does it come out it's not
supposed to it's like a it gets absorbed
into your body it looks like if you snap
the white crayon in half and you took
the front part one wow I I had that as a
kid but I never had it as a I didn't
know oh they they make them in adult
size now yeah as an adult it's supposed
to shoot it no it's it's just like it's
shaped like a bullet so that it goes in
bullets get shot because it's like a
vacuum it just yeah
but if you don't get past that threshold
Point it'll just go oh
yeah I've had a holster you had an a
real ulcer what do you know what caused
it stress how does it how does it feel
College yeah what does it feel like uh
your stomach hurts like crazy so you
constantly end up drinking
um milk to kind of like soften and like
like layer your stomach you have to take
these does it feel painful like sharp
sharp like a dull thing that's a sharp
sharp and then you feel bloated at all
you're [ __ ] black stools so it's
like it's like blood so it's basically
there's like a cut in your stomach
lining and stuff so there's blood that's
actually coming out so when it mixes
with your [ __ ] the blood comes out black
because of your [ __ ] oh my God so that's
like the first Telltale like sign like
you have a stomach ulcer because there's
blood coming out of your stool no yeah
it makes me want to fart
see you've got to push it out you get a
black cloud comes out why are you making
one more I don't know and then it makes
a hole in the ozone then you just have
to take these antacids like over the
counter like antacid pills and stuff
like that um just from school stress no
this is after this is when I was doing
like sales oh why why was this [ __ ] face
doing this to this to his kid because he
was just getting off on like the fact
he's just an evil [ __ ] he's just
an evil [ __ ] he would he would
pour liquids onto the children's bed to
make it look like the family pet
urinated on the sheets like he's just a
[ __ ] weird yeah he's a piece of [ __ ]
every time he likes pranks you know what
this guy like every time you think like
who [ __ ] abuses kids or whatever you
see this guy's picture you're like ah
fits the description you know or like if
someone's like [ __ ] up your like car
and then you just like I just wanted to
get an oil change why is everything
broken he's the mechanic you know like
he's always a guy that looks like that
someone cut your timing belt in half I
don't know who did it but you know what
though I want to say that
um he also looked like he was also
abused don't do that man don't create
Sympathy for the villain
nah dude okay
what a piece of [ __ ] yeah because
there's some people
that don't do that stuff am I right
[Music]
[Music]